What's more impressive than a
Jedi? Two Jedi! But there's one
reason why Ahsoka's powerful dyad
doesn't make all that much sense…
Most of the titles in Ahsoka offer a pretty clear
insight into each episode's themes. "Master and
Apprentice" features the uncomfortable
reunion of Ahsoka Tano and her padawan,
Sabine Wren. "Toil and Trouble" features plenty
of both, and acts as a nifty reference to the
witchy ways of Morgan Elsbeth. "Time to Fly"
gives us a cool space battle and a pod of
space-faring purrgil, while "Fallen Jedi"
deals with the aftermath of Ahsoka's defeat
to Baylan Skoll. "Shadow Warrior'' features
Anakin's return in the World Between Worlds,
and "Far, Far Away" takes us into an
entirely new galaxy. You get the drill.
"Part Seven: Dreams and Madness" takes
things in a more esoteric direction. The
episode does feature plenty of both,
from Baylan's wish to find the hidden
power on Peridea to Thrawn's meddling
with the Nightsisters' magic. However,
the events don't fit the title quite as snugly
as fans of the show might be used to... which
makes "Dreams and Madness" the perfect episode
to whip out a particularly strange Force power.
Early in the episode, Ahsoka locates Sabine by
using the Force to reach out to her. With the
action scenes and plot developments that
follow, it's easy to chalk this up as the
kind of everyday Force shenanigans the Jedi
are known for. However, this being Star Wars,
every single application of the Force has an
extremely detailed history. This particular
power move is known as the Force Dyad,
and it's essentially a bond between two
Force-sensitive individuals. The
most famous Dyadic connection in
the Star Wars franchise is the fraught yet
passionate dynamic between Kylo Ren and Rey,
around which most of the sequel trilogy revolves.
Notably, though, both Kylo and Rey have already
proven themselves as powerful Force-users
by the time their dyad establishes itself.
Here's the problem, though: Because it's been
explicitly stated that Sabine's connection to
the Force is at the lower end of the
scale as far as Jedi apprentices go,
it should be utterly impossible for Ahsoka
to forge such a connection with her.
"Well, I discovered that,
according to Huyang, I'm the
worst candidate to be a Jedi
than any Jedi he has ever known."
Ahsoka's ironclad connection with the Force has
been firmly established over the course of her
many, many appearances in the Star Wars franchise.
In Ahsoka, she's not only a masterful combatant,
but so powerful that she can handily use rare
Force powers like psychometry. Because of this,
it's entirely believable that she might be
able to maintain a Force Dyad connection
to another person. However, the Dyadic
connection historically requires both
sides to be totally in tune with the
Force, which Sabine very much isn't.
While Ahsoka and Sabine clearly share a
strong — if sometimes strained — relationship,
Ahsoka has spent plenty of time hammering
home the apparent fact that Sabine is all
but useless in the ways of the Force. As
such, it should be quite impossible for
Ahsoka to maintain a Force bond with her
padawan. Of course, that's assuming that
Sabine's Force sensitivity is at the virtually
nonexistent level the series has shown so far.
Despite the show's insistence that Sabine is a
low-end Force user at best, Ahsoka has essentially
telegraphed the end of her arc by including
several scenes that tease her successful use
of Force powers. At this point, a scene where she
finally learns to wield the Force is virtually
guaranteed. With that in mind, the fact that
Ahsoka is able to locate her with her apparent
use of a Force Dyad seems like a subtle hint that
Sabine is far more powerful than she realizes. No
doubt, it will be fascinating to see where Ahsoka
takes her as the series reaches its conclusion.